[Music]
a ring doorbell camera captures the
terrifying moment when a woman's
ex-boyfriend is shot and killed by her
father
it happened on july 31st in sydney ohio
allison duckroose says she and her
mother returned home from breakfast when
her ex-boyfriend approached the front
door
when no one answers the door the man
starts to get physical
through all this allison places a call
to 9-1-1
um there's some guy on my front porch
and he won't leave and he's got his
hands behind his back and people answer
me on the ring and he left me a
voicemail on my phone last night where
that voicemail came from 22 year old
james rail who allison says she dated
several years ago hi ellie it's james
i
just
wanted to
reach out to you um
because
i uh i just wanted to uh
see how you're doing it's been a while
since i've talked to you and i feel like
it uh
i don't know what i feel
i do know that i do want to talk to you
though i do
it'd be nice
to be sweet allison later tells
investigators she did not return the
call and like he started to contact me a
couple times and i've ignored it and
then last night he called me at like 11
40. i didn't answer he left me a
voicemail saying hey let's talk
i didn't answer him after rail breaks
through the family's door allison's
father mitchell duckroo calls out with a
warning
seconds later three shots are fired in
rail's direction
[Applause]
ring footage shows rail falling to the
ground before dragging himself toward
the family's garage soon after several
neighbors approached the scene
okay well he's not moving
he broke our door in
did you shoot him yes
meanwhile allison remains on the line
with 9-1-1 and can be heard comforting
her father
you're the best crowd ever you just
saved my eye i know i can't point on me
it's gonna it's gonna be
foreign family stays inside the home
neighbors outside monitor the situation
dude i don't you better hurry up
hey did you already tell them alan yeah
he's dead he's shot he's gone
dude he's about he better he died
i hear him
he's dead he died
several minutes after gunshots rang out
officers arrived to the scene
right here where's the guy with the gun
inside the house he's the homeowner this
guy tried to break in the house okay and
the guy was just baiting to protect
himself
we're right here okay you guys have your
gun down yeah yeah we're right here
officers enter the home and secure the
weapon used in the shooting after that
the duck roof family explains how the
situation began and quickly escalated
was he following all three of you or
just you just you two and you were
already home
knew where i was okay
alison tells officers she had no
communication with rail for several
years until he called her out of the
blue
[Music]
body camera footage also shows allison
embracing her father and later sitting
next to him near the family pool at the
same time other officers secure the
situation in the front of the home and
speak with neighbors
gunshots and i've seen him drop
invasion
the homeowner i mean you see a body
laying there an ohio grand jury later
declined to indict homeowner mitchell
duckroo in the shooting based on stand
your ground laws in the state for the
latest developments in this story and
all things true crime stay with long
crime network i'm sierra gillespie